[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer à la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au programme de l'actualité des
infos pratiques et des idées de sortie
voici le programme de ce 16 novembre
ne pas fumer pendant tous nos ventes
c'est le défi lancé chaque année par le
mois sans tabac éviter la cigarette
durant 30 jours multiplierait par 5 les
chances d'arrêter définitivement on en
parle avec le professeur Loïc Josserand
président d'ACT à Lyon contre le tabac
donner de la voie pour la recherche
contre les cancers pédiatriques
l'association Les bagous à Manon
organise les la voix des bagouses un
grand concours de chant de 7 à 77 ans
les demi-finales et final auront lieu le
14 janvier à Vélizy-Villacoublay à
nerbère à Laurens présidente fondatrice
de l'association et Stan Bennett
président parrain parrain des bagouilles
à Manon sont nos invités enfin qui dit
mercredi dit sortie au cinéma nous
ferons le point sur les nouveautés de la
semaine dans les salles obscures les
conseils des pro aussi pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir un classique du septième art
le réalisateur yvelinois Gauthier Bara
vous dévoilera l'un de ces coups de cœur
les journalistes de la rédaction TV 78
qui sont avec moi en plateau Mathilde
Franco bonsoir à suivre avec vous les
informations du jour de ce mercredi 16
novembre de quoi parle-t-on aujourd'hui
on va parler de rénovation
urbaine et d'un peu de sport puisqu'il y
avait lieu le dernier entraînement de
l'équipe de football de avant de partir
pour la Coupe du monde de football
locataire du côté de Clairefontaine bien
sûr ce centre national du football
installé à dans les Yvelines à
Clairefontaine pour cette équipe de
France de football qui va bientôt
démarrer la compétition également Céline
Charles de la rédaction de TV 78 bonsoir
Céline je le disais on va parler de
sortie cinéma aujourd'hui film 100%
francophone ce soir exactement ce sera
des films 100% francophones mais avec
des genres bien définis on retrouvera
par exemple une auto fiction signée Gad
Elmaleh ou bien le dernier film de
Gaspard uliel et je disais aussi des
invités avec nous en plateau tout à
l'heure le professeur Loïc Josserand qui
nous parlera du mois sans tabac qui se
déroule pendant tout le mois de novembre
il y a également deux invités qui sont
d'ores et déjà avec en plateau à nerbert
Lorenz et Stan Bennett bonsoir à vous
deux merci d'être avec nous alors vous
êtes respectivement président de
fondatrice et par un je disais tout à
l'heure président mais vous êtes le
parrain de l'association Les bagous à
Manon et vous êtes venu me parler de ce
grand concours de chant vers la voie de
la guérison alors les bagouses à Manon
pour présenter cette association on
avait consacré un reportage il y a
quelques mois à votre association les
bagous à Manon ça fait référence à Manon
Anne votre votre fille emporter en 2002
par un neuroblastome à l'aube de ces 8
ans votre association sensibilise le
grand public à la nécessité de soutenir
les projets de recherche sur les cancers
pédiatriques on rappelle que le cancer
c'est la première cause de mortalité par
maladie chez les enfants de plus de 1 an
2000 enfants sont touchés chaque année
en France si c'était un combat 2000
voilà 2500 voilà le dernier chiffre
j'avais le chiffre de 2000 2500 merci de
le préciser et c'est un combat que vous
venez depuis 18 ans ça fera 18 ans le 19
janvier tout à fait et ça a fait 20 ans
cet été que Manon est décédée donc oui
c'est
un combat qui me qui m'anime à 300 %
quels sont les types d'action que que
vous menez alors on avait démarré par
par la fabrication et la vente de bijoux
et puis au bout de 5-6 ans on a bifurqué
vers l'organisation d'événements on a
démarré vers par les événements sportifs
et puis on a eu la chance de rencontrer
Stan qui a décidé de de nous rejoindre
et d'être un par un formidable et depuis
on fait plus dans le dans le spectacle
et dans des soirées bonheur festives et
voilà un concours de chant on va en
parler dans un instant Bennett vous êtes
vous performeur vocal par un de
l'association le disait il y a un
instant Anne ben pourquoi avoir rejoint
justement cette aventure des débatsous à
Manon
parce que je suis sur scène ça me donne
beaucoup de plaisir et si je peux en
donner aussi au public et aussi par
l'intermédiaire de cette association
c'est tout bénef quoi et vous serez le
président du jury des voix des bagouses
on parlera de la voix de des bagous on
en parlera avec vous à rester avec nous
pour en savoir un peu plus dans le 7 8
on revient aussi sur la soirée des
écrivains persécutés empêchés
emprisonnés c'était à la Commanderie de
50 ans en Yvelines hier soir mais avant
tout cela coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
deux mains dans les Yvelines peut-être
quelques rayons de soleil mais surtout
de la pluie au programme le matin il
fera à 11 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Houdan et 10 degrés à Versailles et
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi même
condition avec des températures
légèrement supérieures comptées 12
degrés à Houdan et Versailles à
Mantes-la-Jolie il fera 13 degrés ce
sera 11 degrés à Rambouillet ce jeudi à
17 novembre c'est la saint Elisabeth
[Musique]
et tout de suite les informations du
jour de ce mercredi 16 novembre avec
vous Mathilde Franco et on commence avec
le chiffre du jour 60 pourquoi 60 60
millions d'euros Gregory c'est le
montant qu'on investit les Yvelines dans
la rénovation urbaine hier le président
du Département pierre Bédié a signé les
protocoles de gouvernance de trois
projets les quartiers concernés
Beauregard à Poissy celui des petits
prêts à Élancourt et le quartier de la
Fontaine de Saint-Martin situé à
Saint-Cyr-l'École au total le 25
opérations sont prévues pour réhabiliter
des logements sociaux pour recréer les
des nouvelles habitations ou encore pour
construire des équipements publics
maison médicale centre social ou centre
commercial par exemple
dans quelques instants dans le 7 8 vous
revenez aussi avec nous sur la remise du
des prix du concours national de la
Résistance et de la Déportation
effectivement Grégory est de nombreux
collèges et lycée Yves Linois et ont
participé créé par l'Éducation nationale
en 1961 l'objectif est de faire
perpétuer chez les jeunes Français la
mémoire de la Résistance et de la
Déportation il leur donne aussi
l'occasion de rencontrer directement des
déportés des résistants le thème de
cette année la fin de la guerre les
opérations les répressions les
déportations et la fin du troisième
Reich au total 6 prix ont été remis en
fonction des catégories travailleurs
collectif de voir individuels ou encore
film ou reportage radio
à un axe très emprunté par les Yvelines
notamment pour se rendre vers la
Normandie et ce sera bientôt une
autoroute sans péage en tout cas dans
les Yvelines et oui après la 79 première
autoroute sans barrière de péage en
France qui relie l'Allier et la
Saône-et-Loire la tresse devrait bientôt
suivre c'est en tout cas le projet de la
sanaf Société des autoroutes du Nord et
de l'Est de la France un projet qui
devrait naître à l'horizon 2024 pour
fluidifier la circulation et engendrer
moins de bouchon attention ça veut pas
dire sans pH pas dire qu'on ne paiera
plus l'autoroute tout à fait Grégory il
faudra toujours toujours payer les
traditionnels barrières de péages seront
remplacés par des portiques il capteront
la catégorie du véhicule si c'est une
voiture un camion une moto puis la
plaque d'immatriculation sera
photographiée les automobilistes
pourront payer directement sur leur
téléphone ou sur le site internet dans
les jours suivants pas de changement
pour ceux qui possèdent d'un badge de
télépéage il sera toujours bipé à leur
passage la médiathèque Anatole France
rouvre s'est attrape oui fermez pour les
travaux de rénovation et d'isolation
thermique la médiathèque Anatole France
attrape a finalement réouvert ses portes
hier le mardi 15 novembre après 7 mois
de travaux pour remplacer des chaudières
des éclairages ou encore des vitrages le
public est amené à venir redécouvrir la
médiathèque cependant en ce qui concerne
celle des 7 Mares à Élancourt elle reste
toujours fermée elle devait rouvrir le 4
octobre mais en raison des retards de
livraison ça réouverture est prévue pour
fin novembre début décembre
pour pour la voir c'était le dernier
entraînement des Bleus à Clairefontaine
ce type de France de football qui s'est
envolé aujourd'hui pour le Qatar faites
briller nos étoiles voilà le message qui
était déployé en tribune hier soir
malgré une pluie battante 300 supporters
étaient présents pour venir encourager
les joueurs de l'équipe de France pour
leur seul et dernier entraînement en
France avant la Coupe du Monde au Qatar
de quoi ravir les fans écouter moi je
suis fan du PSG donc
qui va ben n'est pas là mais sinon après
tous les joueurs ont de manière générale
et moi Antoine Griezmann parce que bah
c'est mon genre préféré de l'équipe de
France qui vient de Mbappe parce que je
suis fan de Paris et Karim Benzema parce
que c'est le Ballon d'Or donc forcément
enfin un grand joueur et ouais c'est
important de le voir je vais leur faire
signer un ballon et les cartes on a
donné à Benzema
après il y a Lloris aussi que j'aime
bien Griezmann Giroud voilà un peu ouais
après avoir enchaîné plusieurs passes
les Bleus ont conclu l'entraînement par
une opposition à 10 contredit sur un
quart de terrain Christopher nku s'est
blessé au genou gauche à la suite d'un
choc avec Kama vin gala l'attaquant de
le psyk a fini par se relever pour
quitter le terrain légèrement boiteux
finalement il est forfait pour la Coupe
du Monde il est remplacé par Randall le
colo moani l'attaquant de Francfort le
premier match pour les Bleus sera le 22
novembre contre l'Australie Grégory
est-ce que vous avez un pronostic moi je
suis très mauvais en pronostic en plus
je sais pas si j'ai porté malheur à
l'équipe de France en allant hier à
l'entraînement avec cette blessure de
Christopher nku je vois quand même une
victoire face à l'Australie après j'ai
pas envie de m'avancer sur sur le reste
de la compétition je sais pas vous on
leur souhaite une victoire en tout cas
un pronostic non je vais rester prudente
également
et si vous aussi d'ailleurs près de chez
vous vous êtes témoin d'un fait d'une
information vous avez pu constater un
n'hésitez pas à le partager à le dire
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 7 8 news merci Mathilde pour ces
informations
[Musique]
et on vous en a parlé il y a un instant
dans les informations du jour le
département a signé un protocole de
gouvernance concernant trois projets de
rénovation
urbaine c'est Étienne et pour en parler
Nicolas dandry de la rédaction tv78 nous
a rejoints en plateau bonsoir Nicolas
bonsoir Grégory alors comment le
département s'engage justement dans la
rénovation urbaine et bien Grégory quand
il s'agit de parler de rénovation
urbaine on parle aussi en général de
politique de la ville une action
publique à destination des quartiers et
donc des communes et le département a
décidé de soutenir ce type de projet
hier c'est un investissement de 60
millions d'euros pour trois projets et
globalement dans les quartiers Vinois le
département a investi plus de 500
millions d'euros un demi milliard
d'euros depuis son engagement sur cette
thématique le département de façon
volontaire investit des dizaines de
millions d'euros pour pouvoir permettre
à ces quartiers dégradés de devenir des
quartiers comme les autres et non
seulement nous faisons plus que l'État
dans les quartiers désignés par l'État
au titre de la politique de la ville
mais nous avons aussi créé notre son
propre géographie c'est à dire qu'il y a
des communes qui ne sont pas reconnues
par l'État comme étant des communes
méritants la qualification de quartier
politique de la ville et nous y
intervenons également ce que nous
souhaitons c'est une volonté politique
constante c'est l'égalité territoriale
il ne doit pas y avoir anive un
territoire mieux traité ou moins bien
traité que notre alors pour illustrer
les propos du président du conseil
départemental des Yvelines Grégory et
bien il a l'exemple de Saint-Cyr-l'École
alors cette commune n'est plus classée
comme quartier politique de la ville
mais elle a néanmoins un projet de
rénovation de 58 millions d'euros
soutenus par le département à hauteur de
13 millions d'euros ce projet concerne
le quartier de la Fontaine Saint-Martin
pour rénover des logements réaménager
les zones piétons et créer des espaces
végétalisés on écoute la mère de la
ville soniabro l'engagement du
département auprès de la ville de
Saint-Cyr de la même façon que celui du
bailleur social les résidences Yvelines
Essonne sont les garants de cette
sur Poissy et ça va nous permettre de
refaire complètement le visage du
quartier et de le rendre bien plus
attractif qu'il n'est aujourd'hui la
place racine va être totalement modifiée
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que nous
avons le centre André Malraux qui va
être requalifié complètement refait nous
allons avoir une nouvelle maison
médicale qui va voir le jour donc des
services supplémentaires pour les
habitants et sur les logements eux-mêmes
nous allons avoir une refonte de ces
logements enfin dernier quartier
concerné c'est celui des petits prêts à
Élancourt des rénovations de logements
sont prévus avec quelques démolitions en
concertation avec les habitants objectif
redorer l'attractivité de ce quartier
qui date des années 80 et on écoute
Jean-Michel fourgousse le maire
d'Élancourt c'est un quartier dont
c'était pas assez occupé et ça fait
quand même plusieurs années bien sûr
qu'on a construit un beau projet pour
eux donc là c'est un projet quand même
qui rassemble près de 50 millions et qui
veut dire que c'est là on aura mis
d'ailleurs les plus gros moyens mais
voilà c'est quand même un quartier où il
y avait quand même il y avait beaucoup
de cadrage à faire donc c'est fait ça y
est c'est signé alors voilà donc voilà
en termes de qualité de vie de de cadre
de vie bien sûr de l'aménagement les
appartements bien sûr la la les centres
l'école aussi qui va être aussi
transformé donc c'est vraiment un effort
quand même considérable pour conclure
Grégory baisse ce vendredi 18 novembre
une délibération est à l'ordre du jour
et elle concerne des projets de
rénovation sur les communes de
Rosny-sur-Seine dépônes et de
Sartrouville c'est une enveloppe de 16
millions d'euros qui sera votée par les
conseillers départementaux avec une
assemblée départementale ce vendredi à
l'hôtel du département à Versailles
merci Nicolas pour ces précisions alors
pendant tout le mois de novembre on vous
en parler dans les titres c'est le mois
sans tabac le défi c'est d'arrêter de
fumer pendant 30 jours pour même par la
suite arrêter définitivement la
cigarette il est toujours temps de
rejoindre ce défi même si on en est à la
moitié puisqu'on est à la mi-novembre et
de rejoindre les 157 personnes inscrites
on parle de ce mois sans tabac avec
notre invité qui nous a rejoint en
plateau c'est le professeur Loïc
Josserand bonsoir bonsoir président
d'alliance contre le tabac c'était
alliance contre le tabac on parlera
aussi avec vous de votre nouveau rôle de
doyen de l'UFR Simone santé Simone Veil
santé à l'UVSQ on vous posera quelques
questions dans un instant sur sur cette
thématique là déjà le mois sans tabac le
défi et je le disais c'est d'arrêter
pendant 30 jours de fumer et ça
multiplierait par 5 les chances
d'arrêter définitivement pourquoi c'est
intéressant justement de réfléchir sur
sa consommation du tabac pendant un mois
le mois sans tabac effectivement le mois
de novembre maintenant est devenu du si
je crois que c'est la 7e je crois c'est
la 7e édition de ce mois sans tabac donc
c'est c'est un mois de réflexion où on
va se poser la question de sa propre
consommation de son évolution dans sa
consommation et donc ce mouvement
collectif et on sait très bien quand il
y a une motivation collective quand il y
a une espèce de d'engouement et
d'énergie on est effectivement beaucoup
plus
positivement accompagné beaucoup plus
positif dans sa démarche et on a
effectivement quand on s'arrête un mois
on sait et ça a été montré
scientifiquement en différentes reprises
on a cinq fois plus de chances de
s'arrêter à la fin mais ce qu'il faut
voir même si on y arrive pas au mois de
novembre c'est que c'est pas grave on
est dans une démarche positive et là on
va avancer ça sera peut-être pas le mois
de novembre mais ça sera peut-être le
mois de décembre le mois de janvier avec
les bonnes résolutions ou un mois
suivant de l'année mais c'est pas grave
ce qui est essentiel c'est de rentrer
dans la démarche et de vouloir s'arrêter
et de rentrer dans la tentative d'arrêt
de ne pas être seul vous l'avez dit
c'est très important arrêter mais en
étant accompagné il y a d'ailleurs un
kit d'aide à l'arrêt qui est proposé
pendant ce mois sans tabac on va pouvoir
aussi voir quelques liens s'afficher et
notamment l'accompagnement qui est
proposé pendant ce mois sans tabac avec
deux manières l'application Tabac Info
Service qui propose un i coaching
gratuit et lui aussi un numéro d'appel
gratuit le 39 89 pour bénéficier d'un
suivi d'un tabacologue être accompagné
ces primordial aujourd'hui c'est
difficile d'arrêter être accompagné ça
dépend il y en a qui arrive il y a des
fumeurs qui effectivement arrêtent seuls
mais je pense que si on est accompagné
si on allaite d'un tabacologue que ça
soit à travers une application que ça
soit à travers un soutien téléphonique
avec le 39 89 cette plateforme ça aide
et ça permet vraiment d'avancer dans la
démarche et ça permet vraiment d'aller
définitivement vers le sevrage c'est une
étape essentielle d'être aidé je pense
est un est un véritable atout dans les
chances de réussite et pourquoi c'est si
difficile d'arrêter pourquoi c'est
difficile d'aller vers ce sevrage
justement alors c'est là là on rentre
dans quelque chose effectivement d'un
peu plus long mais on est le tabac
entraîne à travers la nicotine qui qui
contient et qu'on absorbe quand on fume
va entraîner une addiction au niveau
cérébral on a des récepteurs à la
nicotine et ces récepteurs on est on se
sent bien quand ils sont saturés pour le
saturés il y a pas des il y a pas une
infinité de solutions il y en a une
principale c'est celle de fumée donc on
va fumer on va absorber la nicotine à
travers les poumons il faut bien
imaginer qu'il se passe à peine une
seconde le moment où on la nicotine est
dans la cigarette et le moment où elle
est dans le cerveau donc il y a pas plus
rapide comme terme en voie d'absorption
de la nicotine donc ça fait un flash et
ce que le cerveau adore ce sont ses
flashs c'est shoots de nicotine et puis
deuxième partie de l'addiction et là les
fumeurs le disent tous quand ils
s'arrête et qui ne savent plus quoi
faire de leurs mains c'est-à-dire que il
y a aussi l'addiction au geste
l'addiction rituel du tabac avoir une
cigarette la manipuler le paquet
l'ouvrir allumé etc tout ça ça fait et
ça rentre dans l'addiction d'où
effectivement la nécessité aidé soit
avec des produits de substitution
nicotinique qui vont permettre de
saturer ces fameux récepteurs à la
nicotine et donc de ne plus avoir ce
manque de nicotine certains pour
d'autres ça sera la cigarette
électronique là aussi sur un temps dédié
il s'agit pas non plus de rentrer dans
une cigarette électronique sur un très
long terme parce que là on a encore
quelques interrogations sur la sur
l'effet long terme il s'agit pas non
plus et ça c'est important il faut le
rappeler au téléspectateurs vapoter et
fumer en même temps ne réduit pas le
risque et de tabac et n'annule pas la
dépendance au tabac on reste vapo fumeur
mais donc dans vapo il y a fumeur quoi
donc c'est important il faut bien il
faut bien le rappeler quoi Nicolas vous
aviez une question sur le facteur prix
le gouvernement a un projet d'augmenter
encore la fiscalité pour amener le prix
à 15 euros le paquet est-ce que le
facteur prix est déterminant pour
arrêter de fumer le facteur prix est
effectivement un élément déterminant
essentiellement d'ailleurs vers les
jeunes le l'augmentation du prix et le
la cible fiscale du 15 euros en 2027 ce
qui est important à retenir c'est la
trajectoire fiscale que ça représente ça
permet aux fumeurs de se dire dans cinq
ans ça va coûter 15 euros il faut que je
pense à m'arrêter donc ça c'est pour les
fumeurs ensuite les jeunes là il y a un
effet dissuasif sur le prix à 15 euros
on commence à être sur quelque chose qui
qui pose un vrai problème mais le tabac
il faut aller un peu plus loin c'est un
problème de fumeur mais c'est avant tout
un problème social qui nous concerne
tous donc le tabac ça rapporte 13
milliards d'euros par an à l'état ça en
coûte 25 à 25 milliards en frais de
santé et quand on met bout à bout tous
les coups sociaux que ça représente les
incendies l'essence qu'il faut mettre
dans les canadaires etc on est à 120
milliards d'euros donc de toute façon le
tabac ça coûte à chaque Français 1800
euros par an et l'Alliance contre le
tabac sorti un chiffre assez édifiant
sur sur le tabac il y aurait un tiers
des professionnels de santé qui
n'aborderai pas la question du tabagisme
avec leur passion fumeur c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a encore un tabou aujourd'hui
aussi autant de cette question
un problème qui est double pour moi
effectivement d'un côté à l'alliance
aller en tant que président de
l'Alliance effectivement c'est un vrai
souci les professionnels de santé ne se
préoccupent pas encore suffisamment de
c'est la question du tabac auprès de
leur patient or on le sait le simple
fait d'aborder le sujet avec le patient
de l'amène à réfléchir ce qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure sur moi sans tabac donc
si tous les professionnels de santé
posez simplement la question à leur
passion fumeur est-ce que vous fumez oui
non si oui enfin si le patient est
fumeur forcément il va répondre oui mais
est-ce que vous fumez oui et si oui
est-ce que vous pensez arrêter le simple
fait de poser ces deux questions là va
déjà entraîner et déjà entraîner une
réflexion après ma deuxième casquette là
pour le coup de de doyen me dit que il
faut qu'on renforce la formation de nos
étudiants aujourd'hui pour que demain il
soit en mesure de répondre et de prendre
tous en charge le tabac peut-être aussi
davantage de sensibilisation auprès des
plus jeunes et un phénomène inquiétant
inquiétant inquiétant pardon je vais y
arriver celui de la puff je sais pas si
je prononce bien la peur très
précisément qui est une cigarette
électronique jetable aromatisée près
d'un ado sur 10 on a déjà utilisé et
vous appelez de vos vœux justement une
interdiction parce que la vente
normalement est interdite la vente est
interdite aux mineurs c'est un ado sur
10 qui est en capacité de l'acheter
sans aucune limite et sans aucun
contrôle de son âge et ça entre 13 et 16
ans nous nomme sortir des chiffres c'est
13% qui utilisent ce produit là donc on
est en train de se battre sur le tabac
mais si on ne fait rien sur la poche on
est déjà en train de créer la future
génération de fumeurs pour les vins ou
30 prochaines années et il faut bien
voir que c'est un produit qui initie et
c'est une porte d'entrée vers le tabac
mais c'est aussi j'ai un vrai souci
environnemental c'est c'est un
dispositif à usage unique qu'on va
consommer en quelques dizaines de
minutes qui va finir par terre dans les
caniveaux qui contient des résidus de
liquide qui contient une batterie au
lithium et un emballage en plastique
enfin c'est une horreur c'est une
abomination environnementale et c'est
une abomination en matière de santé donc
nous demandons purement et simplement
l'interdiction de se produit là puisque
personne ne respecte l'interdiction de
vente aux mineurs c'est une porte
d'entrée et derrière c'est un vrai c'est
une vraie gabgie environnementale une
proposition de loi qui a été déposée sur
le sujet a été déposée effectivement par
une par une députée d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts pour aller dans ce sens là et
je pense que c'est un projet de loi qui
doit être soutenu de façon trans
partisane quel que soit ses idées
politiques je pense qu'il faut soutenir
un tel projet de loi on est en train de
parler de la santé de nos enfants pour
les 20 prochaines années et de la santé
environnementale qui pour le coup nous
concerne véritablement tous mais pour le
coup c'est aussi l'idée de déconstruire
une idée un peu cool aussi du tabac
de l'UFR qui est une grosse UFR de santé
on fait partie des des décises UFR de
santé d'Île-de-France donc nous sommes
vraiment dans le grand ouest parisien
donc c'est très bien
7500 étudiants on le réalise pas
forcément mais c'est quand même une
grosse UFR alors tous les étudiants bien
sûr ne sont pas sur site mais
les étudiants en médecine qui sont qui
sont là et c'est vrai qu'on parle très
souvent de l'UFR à travers ses étudiants
en médecine je pense que nous devons
avoir et ce que je veux faire et ce que
j'ai déjà commencé à travailler c'est
justement de mettre l'UFR dans une
dynamique de
responsabilité sociale de d'université
promotrice de santé je pense que c'est
important que l'UFR aujourd'hui qui
allait bien construite elle est bien
établie elle a des vrais fondements
scientifiques il faut maintenant qu'on
sache peut-être se tourner vers vers
notre territoire vers la population qui
est autour nos étudiants ils viennent de
notre territoire je pense que il faut on
a besoin de médecins sur notre
territoire on doit former des médecins
du territoire donc je pense que plus
important qu'on aille justement et qu'on
rentre dans cette démarche là je
regretterai vraiment que des lycéens
aujourd'hui parce qu'on va rentrer sur
parcoursup des lycéens aujourd'hui
ce censure dans le fait de vouloir faire
médecine je pense qu'il faut qu'on aille
il faut qu'on décomplexie tous les
lycéens aujourd'hui qui ont envie de
faire médecine il faut qu'ils sachent
que il y a des voies différentes on va
organiser des portes ouvertes dans
quelques mois il faut qu'il sache qu'il
y a des voies différentes pour faire
médecine c'est pas forcément ces
concours extrêmement compliqués qu'on
avait il y a pas une voie royale il y a
pas le Pass Royal il y a des lasses qui
facilitent il y a des passerelles qui
facilitent les accès et je pense qu'il
faut vraiment que les études les lycéens
les étudiants aujourd'hui se renseignent
sur les façons qu'on peut avoir de faire
médecine pour derrière comme on est
habitant du territoire on va s'investir
dans le territoire et on parle
régulièrement de sous densité médicale
le territoire y est et je pense que
c'est aussi la part de l'UFR doit par sa
doit prendre sa part pardon pour
apporter une meilleure santé aux
résidents du territoire merci à vous un
professeur Loïc Josserand je rappelle
doyen donc de l'UFR Simone Veil santé de
l'UVSQ également Président d'asseté
Allianz contre le taeuse qu'on a parlé
avec vous effectivement de ce mois sans
tabac toujours sur le volet santé HF
prévention santé était en Allemagne il y
a quelques semaines l'association basée
à Trappes s'est rendu à Berlin pour une
série de rencontre et de table ronde un
projet soutenu par le fond citoyen
franco-allemand en collaboration avec
l'association bleu blanc rose elle était
Matic abordée la santé sexuelle
homophobie et la lutte contre les
discriminations
lgbtqia plus quelle est la situation à
Berlin sur ce dernier thème on regarde
un extrait un
îlot c'est un peu comme Paris dès qu'on
sort un peu des sentiers battus de
Berlin bon là c'est un peu compliqué ça
c'est la banlieue dès qu'on est un peu
en banlieue donc là ça devient beaucoup
plus difficile ok en fait c'est vraiment
la campagne Berlin on sort de Berlin
c'est la campagne il y a pas une vraie
banlieue d'accord donc en fait voilà
c'est pas cette problématique en France
avec la banlieue non en fait il y a
Berlin et déjà Berlin voilà c'est
certain quartier on va dire mais c'est
plus des quartiers en fait à Paris c'est
vrai qu'elle m'arrêt ici on va dire que
c'est ici c'est Schenberg le grand
quartier mais il y a quand même des
petits îlots il y a des petits illoguets
dans tout Berlin voilà donc là vous avez
encore donc des discothèques des barres
des boîtes des choses comme ça voilà
tout ça a déjà disparu parce que c'est
vrai que nous par exemple sur la région
parisienne mais pas seulement un peu
partout en France on a beaucoup moins
d'établissements par rapport à avant
vous l'analysez commence à chez vous
c'est en train de disparaître ou ça ou
c'est maintenu
il y a des rumeurs qui disent qu'il y a
certains clubs vont fermer certains mais
pour l'instant c'est pas concret mais
pour l'instant on voit pour l'instant on
voit pas ça on voit pas des petits on
voit des petits des petits trucs qui
changent d'adresse qui changent mais ils
existent toujours
et l'intégralité de ces interviews de
ces tables rondes réalisées par
l'association HF prévention sont à
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux de
l'association trappiste on le disait
tout à l'heure et on parlait de ce
concours grand concours organisé par
l'association Les bagous à Manon
l'objectif c'est de donner de la voix
pour la recherche sur les cancers
pédiatriques ce grand concours de chant
s'appelle la voie des bagous ensemble
vers la voie de la guérison il s'adresse
aux 7 à 77 ans et candidature sont à
transmettre avant le 7 décembre la
grande finale est prévue le 14 janvier
il y aura même des demi-finales qui
précèderont et ce sera la salle Ravel de
Vélizy-Villacoublay deux invités sont
avec moi en Platon on les avait tout à
l'heure ils sont revenus à nerbert
Lorraine présidente fondatrice de
l'association Les bagous à Manon et Stan
Bennett qui le parrain de cette
association première question j'ai envie
de vous dire pourquoi un concours de
chant pourquoi organiser ce concours de
chant vous avez commencé à en parler
tout à l'heure harnais Lawrence de
donner aussi de faire des un peu plus
festive mais pourquoi un concours de
chant c'est une votre idée il me semble
en 2019
on a décidé de faire mon spectacle j'ai
partagé le plateau avec un autre
humoriste on l'a fait à la salle Ravel
avant qu'elle soit rénovée c'est tombé
quoi 5 jours avant le confinement c'est
29 février 2020
cette année on a fait 5 artistes à
Vélizy ça a été génial ça a été un peu
plus compliqué parce que il a fallu
jauger au niveau de de la jauge sur sur
place également on pouvait pas faire de
restauration parce que j'avais compris
donc il y a eu une centaine de personnes
c'était pas énorme et on s'est dit
pourquoi pas moi j'ai un nouveau
spectacle je joue actuellement mais
pourquoi pas faire un concours de chant
ça va ramener non seulement donc des
gens c'est intéressant je l'ai déjà fait
dans le Nord je l'ai déjà fait dans le
Sud-Ouest
c'est super sympa et puis c'est pour la
sauce surtout oui parce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure l'objectif c'est
d'organiser aujourd'hui ces soirées plus
festives d'avoir un côté peut-être
ludique pour parler aussi d'un sujet
derrière qui est lourd on le disait
votre association sensibilise le grand
public à la nacité de soutenir justement
ses projets de recherche sur les cancers
pédiatriques lui donner un volet festif
organisé ce genre d'événement c'est
important pour vous c'est-à-dire que
pour moi au départ c'est ces données du
sens à quelque chose qui n'en a pas et
de manière joyeuse parce que la cause
est relativement
rude
tragique pour beaucoup mais voilà moi je
ce qui me guide chaque jour c'est c'est
l'amour de la vie c'est ce que Manon a
aimé et donc on fait beaucoup de choses
avec beaucoup d'humour et et ça permet
aussi de
de ramener un public qui qui peut être
frileux face à une cause
telle que le cancer pédiatrique
et souvent quand ils nous voient alors
que ce soit Stan moi les bénévoles voilà
on est dans la vie et on veut que ce
soit festif pour tous donc là le
concours de chant
c'est c'est quelque chose qui qui va
donner
une lumière différente
sur la cause
sachant que c'est aussi avec 2500 voix
donc pour ça fait ça fait cinq ans
maintenant qu'on qu'on travaille en
partenariat avec eux sur sur ces
soirées-là ben voilà 2500 voix la voix
des bagouses et la voie vers la vers la
guérison
en fait pour pour 2500 voix alors en
fait les les candidats s'inscrivent en
ligne sur sur notre plateforme eloio et
on leur demande de participer à hauteur
de 5 euros sachant que l'intégralité des
5 euros est reversé pour réacteur Kid
donc qui est un collectif de de
chercheurs français
en recherche fondamentale sur les
cancers pédiatriques et le lien et
l'oiseau est assez long donc le plus
simple c'est d'aller sur une page
Facebook des bagous à Manon et on
retrouve très facilement ce lien pour
pouvoir justement s'inscrire à ce
concours Stan qui est adressé au 7 à 77
ans l'idée c'était aussi de concerner
tous les tous les publics c'est
simplement pour dire pour la forme
et c'est tous les styles de musique ça
peut être oui alors plutôt sur bande
parce que on m'a posé la question est-ce
qu'on peut venir avec des musiciens au
niveau de la logistique ça risque d'être
compliqué donc comme si c'est un
concours il faut faire très vite et
c'est plutôt sur bande nous on va le
faire à l'aveugle je l'ai fait par le
passé c'est super sympa niveau sensoriel
on découvre plein de trucs et puis même
pour les candidats donc Anne retrouve
tous les entre guillemets le prix
casting pour pouvoir regarder un peu ce
qui se passe avec une autre personne et
nous donc je serai avec deux profs de
chant et puis une chanteuse
pour pouvoir faire cette demi-finale
cette finale première fois l'aveugle en
fait si ça vous êtes le président du
jury qui va faire une une première
sélection juste avant comment candidate
alors vous l'avez dit on se rend sur ce
lien hello qu'est-ce qu'il faut
transmettre
nom prénom âge pour les mineurs il y a
un formulaire
d'autorisation parentale et en même
temps que que l'on s'inscrit on copie
colle le lien vers sa vidéo de chant que
ce soit Vimeo YouTube ou autre support
oui ça y est on commence par recevoir
des candidatures
vous allez ensuite sélectionner les demi
finalistes ce sera le 15 décembre que
les noms seront révélés pour cette
grande soirée du 14
janviere et puis lors de la soirée du 14
janvier on en prendra 4 après la
demi-finale pour en garder en finale et
puis qui est donc les quatre finalistes
et puis un vainqueur voilà donc le 14
janvier ce sera la salle Ravel de
Vélizy-Villacoublay c'est l'occasion de
la soirée annuelle de l'association Les
bagous à Manon il y a que le jury qui
décide est-ce que le public aura son mot
à dire sur sur la finale
si vous voulez rester dans le château
dans Ça c'est une autre émission qu'y
a-t-il à remporté pour le gagnant
qu'est-ce qu'il y a la clé alors c'est
Magali Mathilde Mathilde
il y a pour le il y a un micro Shure il
y a un micro il y a deux premières
parties on est parti là-dessus moi je
suis en spectacle actuellement sur Paris
dans un cabaret où je fais mon spectacle
complet de dimanche par mois et j'ai
proposé de faire deux premières parties
au vainqueur donc c'est un spectacle
dans un mythique donc ça peut être très
sympa pour quelqu'un qui qui entre
guillemets semi-pro amateur de faire une
première partie là-bas donc à Milo
exactement et puis il y a un lien sur un
massage
balinais puisqu'on a un partenariat avec
les spams à Mama Bali Paris et donc le
le grand gagnant de la finale remporte
tous ces lots le second aura également
un soin et de toute façon il y aura un
petit cadeau pour chacun la question
Mathilde
est-ce que si ça se passe bien ça vous
plaît à organiser vous allez peut-être
en organiser une seconde d'édition
pourquoi pas
c'est de le faire connaître et c'est
vrai que c'est c'est vraiment ludique
c'est sympathique et puis bah pour la
bonne cause c'est c'est chouette
merci Anne merci Stan d'être venu en
plateau vous vouliez ajouter quelque
chose peut-être mais juste de dire que
comme on avait ouvert le champ de cette
à 77 ans moi je suis toujours très
touchée de voir des jeunes qui
s'engagent pour les jeunes et la
première candidature qu'on a reçu c'est
une jeune fille de 13 ans donc c'est
vrai que ça me touche toujours de voir
des enfants s'engager pour des enfants
voilà qui s'engagent pour pour cette
cause et je vous le rappelle la voix des
bagousins ce casting est ouvert le
casting de ce concours jusqu'au 7
décembre on disait tout à l'heure il y a
une page hello à saut qui est dédiée on
trouve très facilement le lien sur la
page Facebook de l'Association des
bagous à Manon merci à vous deux d'être
venu en parler en plateau et tout de
suite la suite du 7 8 avec une page
culture
[Musique]
hier c'était la journée internationale
des écrivains persécutés emprisonnés et
empêchés comme chaque année la
Commanderie à 50 ans de vie n'a profité
de ce rendez-vous pour organiser une
table ronde des journalistes et auteurs
victimes de répression et de censure
dans leur pays pour leur écrit ont pu
témoigner regarder ce reportage de
Julien le roi
la liberté d'expression à tout prix
c'était le message qui était venu
partager les journalistes et auteurs
exilés en France autour d'une table
ronde à la Commanderie high en cours
dans le cadre de la Journée
internationale des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés empêchés c'était moins
m'étaient en avant la répression et la
censure subie pour leurs idées dans leur
propre pays ce qui est inspirant c'est
surtout le parcours de ces personnes la
résilience le courage et puis ça permet
aussi de relativiser et peut-être de
mettre en avant la situation française
et de se dire que finalement ici on est
pas si mal Simon sullimani journaliste
kurde a été emprisonné pendant 16 mois
après la tentative de coup d'État en
2016 pour ses oppositions au pouvoir
turc après sa libération provisoire il
quittait illégalement le pays à la nage
pour atteindre la Grèce il est
aujourd'hui en France et continue
d'exercer pour alerter sur la situation
en Turquie nous avons beaucoup d'amis
journalistes dans la région qui ne peut
pas diffuser les nouvelles dans son sous
ce nom là parce que le gouvernement
toujours menace on prépare ici on
diffuse ici en sécurité enfin en fait
France ça nous donne cette chance de
partager les nouvelles Michael bachirov
auteur de théâtre et de nature russe
subissait la censure de ses œuvres en
Russie il faisait face à des menaces et
intimidation des services de police avec
sa femme réalisatrice un de mes
spectacles il était vraiment interdit
par la police parce que la police elle
est venue au spectacle votre spectacle
aux mille notre président notre état
notre société tatata et ça continuait
faire ce spectacle ça devenu dangereux
pour notre équipe la guerre en Ukraine
la poussée à fuir son pays avec sa femme
et son enfant
70 personnes étaient venues assister à
cette table ronde ce qui m'a beaucoup
marqué c'est c'est l'histoire de leur
parcours c'est la manière dont ils se
sont battus pour leurs idées pour leur
liberté et pour venir jusqu'ici moi je
me sens toujours un peu un peu
silencieux par rapport à de tel de tels
parcours en parallèle de cette soirée
ces intervenants mènent des
sensibilisations auprès des jeunes
autour de la liberté d'expression dans
les écoles 50 images
mercredi c'est jour de sortie de
nouveautés au cinéma vous nous diriez
quel film vous allez voir cette semaine
Mathilde Franco mais on va se tourner de
l'autre côté de la table avec Céline
Charles qui était déjà avec nous et qui
est revenu en plateau pour nous parler
des sorties de la semaine avec une
semaine on peut le dire 100 %
francophone oui ce sera que des films
francophones on commence cette sélection
avec plus que jamais un film d'Émilie
Atef c'est la dernière apparition à
l'écran de l'acteur Gaspard Ulliel comme
vous le savez décédé en janvier dernier
des suites d'un accident de ski le film
raconte une histoire d'amour profond
mais malheureusement marquée par la
maladie Hélène et Mathieu sont heureux
ensemble mais lorsque la jeune femme
apprend que sa maladie est incurable
elle décide de tout quitter et de partir
honneur de l'Europe pour chercher la
paix au détriment de celui qu'il aime un
film sublimé par des images tournées en
Norvège qui nous transporte dans ces
paysages évidemment magnifique jeter un
coup d'oeil à la bande-annonce j'ai
besoin de partir pour retrouver un peu
de la légèreté un peu tout ça c'est pas
possible avec moi en fait c'est ça
je veux faire ce voyage même si t'es pas
d'accord
[Musique]
il faut que tu regardes ça attends la
nature
[Musique]
si tu sors un petit retour à présent
dans les années 80 exactement Grégory
avec les amandiers de Valéria Bruni tes
défis on parle de Stella Etienne Adèle
toute une troupe de jeunes qui ont plus
ou moins 20 ans il passe le concours
d'entrée de la célèbre école créée par
les metteurs en scène pas trichero et
Pierre roman au Théâtre des Amandiers de
Nanterre ce film c'est une véritable ode
à la jeunesse de l'époque avec bien sûr
ces problématiques comme la passion des
planches le jeu l'amour mais également
des thématiques un peu plus sombres
comme le sida ou encore la drogue alors
on va parler maintenant d'un film un peu
plus léger c'est le retour de Gad
Elmaleh devant et derrière la caméra
pour son nouveau film reste un peu il
réalise et joue son propre rôle alors
après trois ans passés aux États-Unis
Gad Elmaleh décide de rentrer en France
pour retrouver ses amis et sa famille
mais ce n'est pas seulement pour les
beaux yeux de sa maman qu'il a décidé de
rentrer une autre femme semble avoir
pris une grande place dans sa vie et il
s'agit de la Vierge Marie l'acteur est
en pleine crise de foi et semble vouloir
délaisser le judaïsme pour le
catholicisme une action qui déclenchera
quelques émois autour de lui regarder
restez avec mon chéri
[Musique]
pourquoi tu es revenu c'est chaud
j'arrive pas à le dire tu es pas mal
j'espère non je suis pas malade
David
j'ai demandé le baptême mais je vais me
faire baptiser tu es pas sérieux là tu
veux pas te convertir au catholicisme
mais je sais quoi ça j'ai trouvé dans la
valise de gâteau
adopter
[Musique]
c'est un film un peu plus personnel que
son ancien il avait fait coco il y a
quelques années alors c'est un air un
petit peu de documentaire puisque c'est
les propres parents et la propre sœur de
Gad Elmaleh qui joue sa famille dans le
film il s'agit de régime Judith et David
Elmaleh on termine avec une autre
comédie dans un registre social cette
fois-ci oui en effet il s'agit du film
Les Femmes du square de Julien Rambaldi
le réalisateur nous plonge dans le
quotidien d'Angèle une jeune ivoirienne
assez précaire qui se débrouille et
survie comme elle le peut jusqu'au jour
elle va se retrouver projeter dans un
tout nouvel univers celui des nunos
Africaines s'occupant des enfants des
beaux quartiers de Paris des femmes
invisibles de la société qui sont bien
souvent exploitées un film sur la
bienveillance l'injustice et la sororité
non personnellement c'est le film qui
m'intéresse le plus même si le film plus
que jamais cette dernière apparition à
l'écran de Gaspard Ulliel aussi
m'intrigue Mathilde pareil les femmes
disent square ouais m'intéresse beaucoup
j'ai vu la bande-annonce et ouais
j'irais bien le voir au cinéma mais le
film de Gad Elmaleh a l'air aussi bien
drôle
j'ai vu la bande-annonce et je sais pas
c'est un air un peu de de ouais la
passion ce qui rappelle un peu la nos
ados nos vies adolescentes en fait
finalement donc
100% francophone pour pour cette semaine
et il y aura donc la France à l'honneur
du 7e art cette semaine dans les 7
obscures on va continuer de parler
cinéma je vais vous donner une petite
réplique vous allez me dire si ça vous
dit quelque chose ils peuvent nous ôter
la vie mais ils ne nous ôteront jamais
notre liberté c'est une réplique célèbre
d'un film
de William Wallace un héros de
l'indépendance écossais ce qui est est
incarné par Mel Gibson le film est sorti
en 1995 et réalisé aussi par Mel Gibson
on parle ici d'un classique et c'est le
coup de cœur cette semaine de notre
réalisateur yvelinois Gauthier Barrail
nous en parle bravehearts le film de Mel
Gibson sorti en 95 avec une BO
exceptionnelle de James Horner alors ce
film est accompagné d'une autre actrice
française que l'on connaît bien Sophie
Marceau remporter plus de 5 oscars ce
film avec un acteur qui est également le
réalisateur donc elle Gibson ici on est
basé au 13e siècle avec William Wallace
William Wallace qui doit se marier en
Écosse dans son pays sauf que
ces dirigé par les Anglais
les seniors anglais ont décidé de
réinstaurer le droit de cuissage et donc
de profiter de la jeune mariée avant le
mariage William là voilà c'est contre il
va donc se marier en secret cette
cachotterie va être découverte par les
seigneurs et donc puni par la loi et à
ce moment-là William Wallace à vouloir
donc se venger et pour ça va monter une
véritable résistance face aux Anglais il
va commencer à vouloir libérer le pays
écossais de cette dictature anglaise on
peut parler officiellement de
chef-d'oeuvre du cinéma car Mel Gibson
en fait Excel sur une chose et
aujourd'hui c'est c'est un
dans la matière en fait sur la
reconstitution de scènes de bataille on
l'a connu dans The Patrick the patriotes
où il n'était juste acteur dedans et on
peut parler de vrai effet histoire en
même temps parce qu'en fait
historiquement rien n'a été prouvé on
peut pas donner de pour ni de contre
donc je vous laisse découvrir ce film
fort en émotion et tout en liberté
il y a le motif freedom dans la version
originale forcément qui qui revient vous
l'avez vu brivert avec une très belle
bande originale c'est vrai faut le
souligner les musiques sont magnifiques
Mathilde moi non j'avoue que jamais vu
le film on l'a dit un multi
oscarisé qui alors est librement inspiré
de la vie de William Wallace mais
aujourd'hui c'était le classique que
nous faisait redécouvrir avec Gauthier
Barra une petite question et on va
passer au dernier sujet ce que vous avez
déjà pratiqué le breakdance est-ce que
ça vous plaît
faut avoir de la technique quand même
pour pratiquer le break days dance votre
avis Céline on en parle souvent sur tv78
en ce moment
les Jeux Olympiques qui vont arriver
avec plusieurs épreuves dans les
Yvelines il n'y aura pas le breakdance
dans les Yvelines mais le breakdance
sera au programme des disciplines
olympiques pour Paris 2024 elle aura
cette occasion il y a un territoire
celui de GPSO la communauté
urbaine qui se mobilise avec son centre
de la danse dans la ville des Mureaux et
qui en partenariat avec une CEP et la
Fédération Française de accueille des
stages de formation pour les entraîneurs
de Breaking le reportage de Gabriel
Gontier
[Musique]
ils sont les entraîneurs de demain c'est
8 bboys et big girl comme on les appelle
se sont retrouvés pour leur deuxième
semaine de formation au centre de la
danse GPSO des Mureaux ils vont obtenir
le premier titre certifiant reconnu par
l'État une ouverture à une
professionnalisation de la discipline
notre projet artistique il est axé
autour justement des Nancy pop et du
breaking donc pour nous ça ça coulait de
source d'avoir ce type de partenariat et
on est très fier de pouvoir accueillir
cette première promotion en partenariat
avec la Fédération Française de danse et
l'INSEP avec 30 millions de pratiquants
dans le monde et un million en France
depuis 2020 le breakdance est reconnu
comme discipline olympique
c'est sur cette héritage de Paris 2024
que repose la formation est allée sur 10
mois les danseurs vont acquérir les
compétences fondamentales du métier
d'entraîneur viens partir du principe il
y a plusieurs écoles il y a plusieurs
visions voilà qui vont vous être
partagés et que chacun avec ses
ambitsibilités à construire son chemin
c'est une formation qui est assez
intense pour eux qui va leur permettre
une acquisition d'un diplôme de niveau 4
donc le titre finalité professionnelle
TFP avec l'intitulé entraîneur breaking
qui va pouvoir leur ouvrir les portes
d'une carte professionnelle aussi donc
reconnu des institutions
le choix des Mureaux pour la formation
n'a pas été un hasard depuis quelques
années ce secteur constitue une plaque
tournante des danses de rue pour keno du
groupe de break yvelinois première
avertissement cette formation est
l'opportunité pour les breakdanceurs de
voir reconnaître leur travail et de
peut-être entraîner un jour l'équipe de
France moi c'est aussi c'est aussi un
défi que j'aimerais réaliser être coach
de l'équipe de France que ça soit au
niveau espoir pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir travailler avec la nouvelle
équipe qui représentera la France pour
les prochains JO habituez-vous à voir
ces figures car la discipline regorge de
talent qui compte bien nous donner le
tournis pour les JO de Paris 2024
breakdance discipline olympique sera une
première dans l'histoire pour Paris 2024
avec des épreuves qui vont se dérouler
du côté de la place de la Concorde on
rappelle que dans les Yvelines de
nombreuses épreuves seront accueillies
on pense au cyclisme sur pays au vélo de
route nationale le golf au golfe
nationale de 50 ans en Yvelines le VTT
sur la colline deslancourt aussi des
épreuves équestres qui seront organisés
du côté de Versailles et d'ailleurs sur
TV 78 on parle des JO dans une nouvelle
émission si on parlait sport Jo 2024 a
retrouvé sur notre site Internet et
notre application mobile avant de vous
quitter un dernier coup d'oeil par la
météo
et plutôt même un dernier coup d'oeil à
la météo demain dans les Yvelines
peut-être quelques rayons de soleil mais
surtout de la pluie au programme le
matin il fera 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan 10 degrés à
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi les mêmes conditions avec
des températures légèrement supérieures
comptées 12 degrés à Houdan et
Versailles à Mantes-la-Jolie le fera 13
degrés ce sera 11 degrés à Houdan et ce
jeudi et 17 novembre nous fêterons les
Elisabeth voilà c'est la fin du 7 8
merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition belle
soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]